monsieur le Président Madame la
Commissaire en juin 2022 notre notre
Parlement appelé à l'ouverture d'une
convention pour réformer nos traité
européens aujourd'hui nous franchissons
une étape cruciale avec le vote de nos
propositions plus d'Europe et mieux
d'Europe c'est ce que nous voulons c'est
surtout ce que les citoyens nous ont
demandé lors de la conférence pour
l'avenir de l'Europe c'est la fin de
l'unanimité au conseil c'est une Europe
renforcée c'est une Europe plus réactive
car les défis qui attendent l'Europe
sont nombreux élargissement défense
européenne protection de nos valeurs
démocratiques rôle de l'UE dans le monde
cette Europe forte ne se fera pas sans
des citoyens unis et éclairés il faut
donner à tous les moyens de comprendre
notre histoire et nos institutions de
résister à la désinformation
nationaliste et cela dès le plus jeune
âge comment pouvons-nous être européens
sans le savoir pour cela chaque citoyen
doit accéder à un minimum d'éducation
civique européenne dans chaque État
membre et cela à a plus de compétences
partagées en la matière c'est un grand
pas que nous faisons ici avec cette
demande et c'est ce pourquoi je me suis
toujours investie merci beaucoup